لم يعد خفيا بان الحرب في اوكرانيا اشعلت
سباق تسلح على مستوى العالم ففي حين مثلا
ضعفت معظم الدول من ميزانيتها الدفاعيه
سرعت العديد من الشركات لتطوير تكنولوجيا
تتماشى مع المتطلبات الجديده للحرب
الحديثه لكن السؤال كيف انعكست هذه الحربه
على الاتجاهات العالميه في الصناعات
العسكريه وهل نحن امام مستقبل جديد
لموازين قوه عالميه مختلفه عن التي ظهرت
بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه ام لا هذا ما
سنناقشه مع الباحث في شؤون الدفاع والامن
الدكتور بيتر سنجر بروفيسور دراسات الامن
العالمي في جامعه ولايه اريزونا والباحث
في المعهد امريكا الجديده للدراسات اولا
همم بروفيسور بيتر اهلا بك معنا في
عسكريتاريا فيما يتعلق بالحرب في اوكرانيا
كيف اثرت على الاتجاهات العالميه في
التسلح وبرايه ما هي اكثر القطاعات داخل
الجيوش تاثرا بعد هذه الحرب
تويتر تويتر
فعاليتها في الحروب التقليديه مثل
المنظومات غير الماهوله او المسيرات التي
استخدمت في الحروب في العراق وافغانستان
مثلا الا ان الهدف الرئيسي من استخدامها
هو مكافحه الارهاب اما في اوكرانيا فقد
اثبتت انها مؤثره وقويه في النزاعات واسعه
النطاق وهذا لا ينطبق فقط على المسيرات
كبيره الحجم مثل المسيرات التركيه بل ايضا
على المنظمات المدنيه الصغيره الامر
الثاني هو ان الحرب تسببت في طلب كبير جدا
للمعاني والذخيره حتى من الجيوش غير
المشاركه في الحرب والدول التي تزوده هذه
المهن مثل امريكا او ايران تعاني لتلبيتها
هذه الطلبات الكبيره في الروس بدات تنفذ
منهم ليس فقط الصواريخ بل ايضا قذائف
المدفعيه والامر المثير الثالث وان البعض
قال ان هناك بعض التكنولوجيا
لم تكن مفيده على الاطلاق مثل الدبابات
التي لم تكن مثيره في الاسابيع الاولى من
النزاع ولكنني اعتقد ان هذا الكلام مبالغ
فيه ولا يعني ذلك ان الدبابات لن يكون لها
دور في الحروب او اننا لن نشهد معارك
بحريه بعد الان بل السبب ان روسيا
استخدمتها بشكل غبي جدا ولذلك فان هذا
الجدل القائمه حول سلاسل لتوريد العالميه
لهذه الاسلحه في النزاعات لن يتحقق وسوف
يستمر بيع الدبابات والسفن القتاليه
الدكتور بيتر افهم من حديث كهذا بانه بعض
الاراء التي خرجت بانه بعض الجيوش بحاجه
الى ترتيب اولوياتها في التسلح بعد ما ظهر
في الحرب في اوكرانيا ليس صحيح على سبيل
المثال ام انه همم بعض الجيوش ما زالت
بحاجه الى اعاده اولوياتها في برامج
التسلق الخاصه بها
الحرب في اوكرانيا وكانها حصه دراسيه او
مختبر بالنسبه لهم وكل دوله تتعلم الدروس
حول ما ينجح وما لا ينجح وكل ما يخص
منظومات الاسلحه وكيفيه استخدامها
وتنظيمها فاستخدام المنظومات غير الماهوله
مثلا اي المسيرات في الحروب التقليديه وفي
هذه المعارك الكبرى دفع كل الجيوش الاخرى
لمراقبه ما يجري وارغمهم على اعاده تقيمهم
لاساليب استخدامه هذه المنظمات وهل عليهم
شراع المزيد منها وكذلك كيفيه الدفاع ضدها
وسوف نشهد زياده كبيره جدا في تكنولوجيا
مكافحه مسيرات جانب اخر هو نوع من التدريب
الذي توفره فمن بين الدروس التي استفادت
بها عده دول حتى الصين على سبيل المثال هو
مستوى ادائي اوكرانيا العالي ومستوى اداء
روسيا الضعيف والكثير من ذلك له علاقه ليس
فقط بالتنظيم بل بالتدريب ايضا وليس فقط
للضباط بل للمجندين ايضا وسيقود ذلك الى
اجراء تغييرات الدكتور بيتر بالتاكيد
الولايات المتحده كانت تراقب ما يحدث في
اوكرانيا لكن هل بعدما ظهر خلال عام من
الحرب هل باتت الولايات المتحده اكثر ااا
ثقه بقدرتها العسكريه ام ان ما حدث على
ارض الواقع كشف للولايات المتحده نقاط ضعف
لم تكن تاخذها في الحسبان في السابق
اعتقد ان كليهما صحيح فمن جهه كان هناك
شبه خوفا من روسيا وما قد تقوم به في
اوروبا والذي تسبب في الكثير من التخطيط
الدفاعي في امريكا ولكن اتضح ان روسيا
ليست بارعها الكثيرون وقد العاكس ذلك في
امور كثيره مثليين القوات الامريكيه في
اوروبا وحتى ما توقعته الكثيرون حول ما
سيحدث في اوكرانيا لكن مع ذلك بان
المسؤولين العسكريين في امريكا
تعرفون ان الخصم الذي يقلقهم اكثر وهو
الصين يدرس ما يحدث في روسيا ولن يرتكب
نفس الاخطاء هناك سؤال ايضا حول انواع
المنظمات التي احتوت على بعض الثغرات الا
انها اثبتت انها مفيده جدا في اوكرانيا
مثل المسيرات الكبيره وكذلك الصغيره التي
اطلقت بمجموعات كبيره وهذا شيء لم تقم به
امريكا الى ان استخدمها الاوكرانيون
والروس في فاعليه كبيره مما دفع الجيش
الامريكي للتفكير في كيفيه استخدامها
وكذلك كيفيه الدفاع ضدها اذا ما استخدمت
لمهاجمه وحداتها تمام الدكتور بيتر من
انهيار الجدار برلين ونحن امام ملامح
واضحه لموازين القوه في العالم الان هناك
قوى صاعده كثيره سواء الصين او كوريا
الجنوبيه او اليابان او بعض الدول الان
لديها طموحات عسكريه كبيره وكذلك طموحات
اقتصاديه هل تعتقد بانه يعني السنوات
القادمه من الممكن ان يكون هناك موازين
قوه جديده غير المتعارف عليها منذ انهيار
جدار برلين
بشكل كبير ببروز الصين ليس فقط كقوه
اقتصاديه او سياسيه بنك قوه عسكريه خارقه
ستكون واحده من اهم قصص القرن الحادي
والعشرين الجو السياسيه والمساله لا تخص
فقط ما ستقوم به الصين مع هذه القوه
الخارقه والنفوذ التي تسعى لتحقيقه ليس
فقط
وجودها المتنامي في كل مكان مثل الشرق
الاوسط وافريقيا وامريكا اللاتينيه وكذلك
كيف ستستجيب الدول الاخرى للصيني هل ستسعى
لتحقيق التوازن معها وتشكيل معارضه اذا ما
رات ان الصينه تشكل لهم تحديدا ام تنضم
اليها وتكون الصين قادره على جذبهم سواء
عبر المحفزات او التحديدات هذه هي دينا
ملكيه القوه التي تخلط الاوراق ليس اسيا
بل حتى في النقاشات حول ما سيحدث لاحقا في
الشرق الاوسط
الدكتور بيتر الحرب في اوكرانيا اظهرت نوع
جديد من التحالفات العسكريه ربما البعض
يسميها تحالفات الضروره مثل التحالف
العسكري الموجود حاليا ما بين ايران
وروسيا من جانب لكن برايك الى ما اي مدى
هذه التحالفات قادره على الصمود خاصه بانه
مثل هذه التحالفات ليست مبنيه على توافق
فكري او ايديولوجي ما بين الانظمه الحاكمه
لهذه الدول
دقيق فهذه التحالفات قائمه على الصفقات
وهي تركز على المعارضه المشتركه اكثر من
تركيزها على الايديولوجيا او القيم
المشتركه وهذا يشمل العلاقه بين روسيا
وايران او حتى بين روسيا والصين ما تغير
في العام الماضي هو موقف القوه في تلك
العلاقات في العلاقه بين روسيا وايران
مثلا ايران اصبح لديها موقف قوه اعظم
نسبيا من روسيا لانها اصبحت الطرف الذي
يزود روسيا بمنظومات الاسلحه التي تحتاجها
الاخيره وبالتحديد الصواريخ والمسيرات نفس
الشيء ينطبق على الصين حيث كان بوتا يرى
نفسه ندا وشريكا الا انه الطرف الاضعف في
العلاقه وهو مثل الشقيق الاصغر ولقد
شاهدنا ذلك باشكال واضحه للعيان مثل اسلوب
معاملته في القمم العالميه وكذلك باشكالا
تعاملت فيها الصين مع روسيا خلف الكواليس
مثل الاشياء التي وافقت الصين على تزويدها
لروسيا واشياء اخرى رفضت تزويدها لروسيا
وحتى اسعاره شراء الطاقه من روسيا في
الصين كانت متحالفه مع روسيا الا انها في
نفس الوقت استغلت هذه العلاقه ان صح
التعبير دكتور
الجديده شكرا جزيلا على كل ما تفضل به